for the last
like 50 or 60 years space has mostly
been dominated by
a handful of governments it took
government money to get a rocket up to
build a satellite
around sort of 2008 the launch of this
falcon 1 rocket made by spacex that
marked the first time we had
billionaires
who had some success in space
and now we're at this really interesting
moment in time where
i think pretty much inspired by this
example everybody decided they could do
space
as well and could take a crack at these
things that people have been dreaming
about for
almost a century we've gone from
governments to billionaires to now
all this private money venture
capitalists
just regular old millionaires flooding
into space and funding
all kinds of projects as space becomes
more accessible to private enterprise
many companies are hoping to make it not
just possible but affordable
to put objects into orbit
now a rocket startup called astra is on
the verge of launching rockets at a
fraction
of the cost of its competitors
potentially opening up a new era in the
technology and business of space
as i look 50 years into the future i see
a platform emerging in space and right
above that thin blue line
i see competition i see ecosystems that
are that are global
i see standards emerging and i see a
really exciting opportunity
for a trillion plus dollar economy to
form
my name is chris kemp i'm the founder
chairman and ceo of astra
and we're in our rocket factory located
just across the bay bridge
from san francisco and alameda
california
and i think that astra is really
offering a very unique service uh no one
can go
anywhere on earth and and and put
something anywhere in space
in a few days with a few people we
started talking about
basically the idea of building a rocket
factory from the very beginning
and this idea was based on the principle
that if you make a lot of something the
cost comes down a lot
so we're building hondas not ferraris
we don't use any of the exotic materials
carbon fiber composites
3d printing that a lot of other
companies like to talk a lot about
they're actually very expensive and
they're very hard to scale so we're
building these rockets out of aluminum
so we're we're bending we're welding
we're fastening we're stamping we're
machining
aluminum but our thesis was that if you
could build rockets like like an
aircraft or an
automobile we could really bring the
economics in line with some of these
larger rockets
astra is entering into a crowded and
well-funded space
spacex is the clear leader with its
falcon 9
falcon heavy and falcon super-heavy
rockets
another front-runner is new
zealand-based rocket lab with their
electron and neutron rockets
astra has announced two different models
one small
one big and says both will be much
faster and cheaper to build than those
of its competitors
for like a hundred years people in the
united states
germany russia have been trying to build
one of these small
liquid-fueled rockets the first private
company to really pull it off was spacex
in 2008 it took spacex seven years to go
from nothing
to getting this first rocket up astra's
whole goal
really was to try and shrink that time
as much as possible
and to develop and manufacture this type
of rocket faster than any company
in history over the next few years here
at this facility
we'll be increasing the production rate
of rockets from monthly
this year to weekly in 2023 to bi-weekly
in 2024
to a full daily production rate in 2025
and by launching a rocket a day we'll be
able to bring the price point down
uh to about a half a million dollars and
uh we'll be selling launches for a few
million dollars that can deliver between
three and 500 kilograms to low earth
orbit
astra's ambition was born from the
massive demand for getting small
satellites into low earth orbit startups
are lining up to hitch rides on bigger
rockets
often waiting months or years for their
turn well about five years ago
one of my best friends started planet
which was the pioneer in building small
satellites
and they were having some real trouble
getting to space after spending a few
months meeting a bunch of the other
rocket companies it was pretty clear
that
he needed to be able to get from
anywhere on earth to anywhere in space
on his schedule not the schedule of some
large satellite
if you're a small satellite company and
you want to get on a spacex rocket
the going rate for a spacex launch is
about 60 million dollars
and there's going to be one or two very
large
satellites that are on that rocket and
they're really the primary
payload all these startups want to be
these what they call secondary payloads
they're sort of attached around the big
satellites and so you're paying
almost to be like a second class citizen
on this rocket the large satellites the
people that are really paying for the
bulk of the launch they get
deposited exactly in the orbit that they
want
then the secondary satellites get
dropped off and
usually they have to use really small
thrusters
on the satellites then to kind of push
themselves into their
desired orbit there's not as many
guarantees that you're going to end up
in the right spot companies like planet
labs are aiming to dispatch many tiny
satellites all around the globe
in what's called a constellation the
satellites can do various computational
tasks using data from all over the earth
and since they're tiny and sit in low
earth orbit they just burn up in the
atmosphere after a while
rather than contributing to the growing
problem of space debris
as more and more companies try to build
systems like this the need for easy
access to space
is becoming greater and greater that's
where astra comes in
the idea with the small rockets is that
you're getting your own ride to space
it's taking your satellite to exactly
the orbit you want
and even more than that you're not
having to wait months and months and
months to find space
on a launch the whole idea here with
something like astra is you hop on a
website
you book a rocket launch you send them
your satellite and
hopefully in a couple weeks your
satellite's up in orbit so we've never
seen anything like this sort of
access to space and the pace at which
you could fly something
into space in much the same way amazon
has
big warehouses and and trucks that pull
up
you wouldn't land an airbus 380 on
market street and deliver a package to
me
a little little sprinter van pulls up
and someone walks up and delivers a
package
just look back at the last 10 years
we've seen almost 400 companies now
formed solving all sorts of really
interesting problems
looking at the earth looking at how
crops are growing looking at where we're
fishing
oceans looking at how to prevent things
like coral reefs
being overheated in the oceans and
understanding weather patterns
i can't imagine all the applications
while private space flight is becoming
an increasingly crowded field
the success rate is still extremely low
more than 20 rocket startups have now
failed and there are at least
80 others currently trying to get off
the ground
only two private companies spacex and
rocket lab
are flying regular missions to space and
astra
could be on the verge of becoming the
third so astro's been at it for about
four or five years they've done really
well
in many senses they actually got to
alaska and did their first launch in
about two years which was a record
rocket launch in kodiak alaska
pretty cool
the downside of that launch was that the
rocket blew up
whoa it took up a couple more tries
and then just at the end of last year
they had really
what was for all intents and purposes a
tremendous success their rocket got like
just to the edge of low earth orbit
within really
a few feet and so we know now
that the rocket works the company
plans to launch another rocket later
this year as they continue to inch
towards making commercial flights
eventually they hope to launch a rocket
every single day
which could lead to an exponential
increase in the number of satellites in
orbit
i mean we're at this super interesting
time that i don't think most people are
paying attention to which is that
at the start of this year there are
probably about 2 200
satellites roughly orbiting the earth if
you look
at the launch manifests of the various
rocket
and satellite companies that number is
supposed to go to about fifty thousand
to a hundred thousand satellites
in the next five to ten years this is
the next great
technology story the next great
computing infrastructure
story is what's going to happen right
above our heads and so
the next few years are going to bring
with them this unbelievable
frenetic amount of activity both from
the rocket companies
and the satellite companies and really
all the global powers kind of
understanding the new rules of
engagement that go in
to this era when when governments do not
control
this real estate that had been the most
prized expensive real estate
there is now just about anyone with a
decent amount of money
and a decent amount of brains can get to
space and do something interesting there
our customers will be able to go from a
concept to a constellation
to really helping improve life on earth
in months instead of many years
and that's that's really our purpose and
i think over the next few years you'll
see us
really make it easier to allow space to
be a platform
for entrepreneurs across the world
you